thank you just to recap on the breaking
news that we have had in in the last few
minutes the Prime Minister has sacked
Nadeem zahawi as party chairman this is
after a report by his ethics advisor
into Nadeem zahawi's tax Affairs he says
in the letter following new information
which came to light in recent days
regarding your personal financial
arrangements and declarations I asked
Solari Magnus the independent advisor on
Minister's interests to fully
investigate this matter you agreed and
then he says following the completion of
the investigation it is clear that there
has been a serious breach of the
ministerial code as a result I have
informed you with my decision to remove
you from your position in his Majesty's
government
well let's get some analysis on this
story uh shall we we can talk now to our
Deputy political editor Sam Coates who's
with us this morning uh Sam do you think
there's a sense of inevitability to this
there was Sophie but it has taken eight
days since Nadine zahari issued a
statement uh defending himself a
seven-day investigation in order to come
to the conclusion that Richie sunac has
made this morning that Nadim zahawi is
out of his government now it's
extraordinary really that just a year
ago or so Nadine zahal we was
contemplating trying to be a prime
minister of this country yet what had
already happened with his tax Affairs
ended up essentially sowing the seeds
for his dismissal for it's a blunt
dismissal doesn't look like there was an
opportunity given to Nadine zahalby to
resign his dismissal from government now
he is out one time quite popular
Minister he was been campaigning for his
job over the last uh seven days or so he
was in checkers with the Prime Minister
just a few days ago he's been leaning on
colleagues to back him uh his aides have
been making taking the case to keep him
in government but no this morning Rishi
sunak makes clear he has decided that
Nadine zahawi is out and out in a pretty
brutal fashion but we've got more
information for you Sophie because we
know why in quite a lot of detail
because in addition to the letter that
Downing Street has released from the
prime minister to Nadim zahawi
dismissing him we also have the letter
it's a four-page letter from solori
Magnus to the Prime Minister outlining
why Nadine's a harway couldn't remain in
government and I have to say Sophie it's
one of the most detailed and unsparing
assessment that I can remember from an
independent ministerial advisor on
ethics about a serving cabinet minister
and makes absolutely clear in pitiless
detail why Nadine zahari could not stay
in his job I've got the letter in front
of me let me just run you through some
of the key points that it makes
essentially the conclusion that the
independent ministerial advisor has got
to is that all the period through 2021
and 2022 when hmrc was investigating
Nadine zahawi's case is that he didn't
realize that he was the subject of a
formal investigation and therefore
didn't tell any of the relevant people
that any of the relevant people that he
should have done like permanent
secretaries in the education department
the permanent secretary when he became
Chancellor which oversees hmrc Nadine
zahari didn't admit to them that he was
under investigation by hmrc Lori Magnus
has found and he claims Nadine zahari
claims that that's because whilst he was
aware of a few inquiries he didn't think
that that amounted to be in under
investigation and basically Laurie
Magnus just says that's nonsense he says
uh that that impression that he uh
ministers are expected uh to to
understand what that means uh and I
consider this is Laurie Magnus writing I
consider that an hmrc investigation of
the nature faced by Mr zahari would be a
relevant matter for a minister to
discuss and declare as part of their
Declaration of interest and it's the
kind of thing that you should speak to
your permanent secretary by senior civil
servant in your department about and
it's that failure that failure to tell
the education permanent secretary and
the the permanent secretary uh to the
treasury
um and uh basically he is a fairly
unimpressed with uh Nadim zahawi uh
suggesting uh that he didn't think that
he was uh personally under investigation
he goes on to criticize the public
statements of Nadim zahawi uh Nadim
sahawi uh saying in public uh that it is
um uh people have falsely claimed that
the serious Fraud Office the National
Crime agency and hmrc are looking into
me let me be clear I am not aware of
this I haven't been not told of this
um now Nadine zahari told Laurie Magnus
that he made that statement because he
was under the impression that he was
answering hmrc's queries but was not
under investigation uh but Laurie Magnus
said that he considers an individual
subject to the hmrc process faced by Mr
zahawi should have understood that he
was under investigation by hmrc and that
this was a serious matter incredible
Mrs are always case for the defense was
that even though hmrc are asking me
questions I didn't realize that that
amounted to an investigation and Laurie
Magnus the investment banker has been
appointed Rishi sunax independent ethics
advice just went right I believe that in
the slices clearly you should have known
that that amounted to uh uh to an
investigation and you should not have
made those public statements you should
not have failed to declare it to the
pertinent secretaries in your department
and that's why I think that credibility
gap that I think Lori Magnus feels that
he's found between Nadim zahawi's public
statement his statements inside
government and what was really going on
because Lori Magnus has been able to
talk to hmrc about the long-running
investigation he doesn't say how big the
payment was that Nadine zahawi had to
pay back to hmrc he doesn't say uh
indeed whether there was a penalty
although we believe that there was as
hmlt uh say that they um as an hmrc
found uh what Nadine zahari
characterizes as carelessness but there
was a penalty uh to pay uh for that so
he didn't go into the private tax
Affairs of this but Lori Magnus does
basically saying because you made those
statements internally in government and
to the public which I don't think really
match with the facts you've got to go
now so if there's a really big and
important political Point here because a
lot of people for the last couple of
weeks have been asking why did Richie
seem like a point Nadine zahar we the
first place given that there were lots
of stories in the media about Nadine
zahawi's tax Affairs why didn't he just
ask what was going on now Downing Street
had been absolutely clear that there
were no Flags there were no warnings
from civil servants that there was a
problem with Nadine zahawi's tax Affairs
because the matter had been settled it
was concluded before Rishi tsuna came
along but there has been this this issue
still persisting why didn't Rishi sunak
asked basically ask more questions why
didn't the cabinet secretary perhaps
tell Richie soon that there was this big
fairly recent issue that Nadine zahawi
had had to deal with and and what this
letter does what this four-page letter
from the Independent ministerial adviser
to Rishi to sort of give a different
reason for for sacking him basically
saying that there's things that
Richardson couldn't have known that make
uh Nadim zahawi's position in government
all but untenable this uh the public
statements about how he wasn't in under
investigation by hmrc when he was
something that Laurie Magnus could only
says he can only have found out by
talking to hmrc not something that
Richardson was particularly in a
position to do when he was appointing
jobs in his first cabinet back in the
Autumn and basically says only by doing
my investigation and talking to the
permanent secretaries who were told of
this investigation while it was going on
including uh the permanent Secretary of
the Treasury then Tom scholar who of
course
um was overseeing with Nadine zahawi
hmrc so uh yeah I mean it is just
extraordinary nazim zahawi uh involved
in discussions with the tax man and
being Chancellor overseeing hmrc which
does these negotiations all of that
happening at the same time but but
essentially what Laurie Magnus has done
as well as giving an unsparing account
of why Nadine zahari can't keep his job
is also in to some degree uh providing
cover a shield for Richie sunac
exculcipating the Prime Minister from
not asking enough questions saying it's
only because I know these other things
that were not in the public domain that
were not uh the subject of public
disclosure because of my essentially six
day seven day investigation that that
we've uncovered the real reasons why you
should get rid of him so so some attempt
at shielding the Prime Minister from the
for for from the Fallout but it's a
brutal letter uh the one from the
Independent ministerial advisor Sophie
it just it just is it it concludes uh
that um uh My overall judgment is that
Mr zahawi's conduct as a minister has
fallen below the high standards that
that of prime minister you rightly
expect from those uh who serve in your
government uh the one thing that Lori
Magnus does say is that uh Nadine zahari
fully cooperated I think he felt he had
a case to make uh that he didn't know he
was under full investigation he didn't
realize that these things were a problem
but as you've been hearing uh Lori
Magnus misses out of the water the idea
that Nadine zahawi could be going around
saying he wasn't under investigation
failing to tell permanent secretaries
that he had been or was under
investigation all because the questions
in Nadim zahawi's view as um as he told
the ministerial advisor didn't amount to
a proper formal probe nonsense basically
is what uh Laurie Magda says and that's
why this morning Nadine zahari is no
longer part of the government no longer
conservative party chairman and there's
a reshuffle underway